>> We don't always have
enough time
to cover all of the recent news,
so here with a recap
is one of our writers, Amber
Ruffin,
in a segment we call
"Amber Says What."
[ Theme music plays ]
-You guys,
things have been crazy.
Okay, so, first of all,
a South Carolina man
won the lottery.
And then, 11 days later,
he won it again!
And I was like, "What?!"
Then, at the same exact time,
in Alaska,
three different volcanoes
were erupting!
And I was like,
"What? What? What?"
Then, Lizzo and Cardi B released
their new hit video,
called "Rumors,"
where they're goddesses!
And I was like, "What?!"
Look at how cute they are!
Oh, my gosh.
I'm going to listen to that song
every single day!
I'm listening to it right now!
Their song is about the
importance of spreading rumors.
-I think it's about
the opposite of that.
-Oh, really?
That's not what I heard.
I heard, Seth got Botox.
[ Gasps ]
Then, I heard --
and this one is true --
that a literal hermit
who lives in a cave
got a coronavirus vaccine.
And I was like, "What?!"
A Serbian man emerged
from his cave where he lived
and found out
there was a pandemic,
and immediately got the shot.
So, what is my nephew's excuse,
the little idiot?
The hermit also was like,
"Where can I download 'Rumors'?"
And I was like,
"I got you, Caveman."
He caught it.
Then, Barack Obama turned 60
and had a birthday party!
I was like, "What, what?"
The guest list was
a who's who of celebrities --
Beyoncé, H.E.R., Erykah Badu,
Amber Mildred Ruffin,
John Legend, Chrissy --
-Amber, you were not invited
to Barack's party.
-Oh, really?
That's not what I heard.
[ Gasps ]
-You were not!
-Shut up! Neither were you!
-Shut up!
-Then, Rand Paul got suspended
from YouTube,
and I was like, "What?!
You can get suspended
from YouTube?!
Uh, uh, uh, how?"
You know what's on YouTube?
This.
-Oh!
-But Rand Paul got suspended?!
What could he
have possibly done?
Did he show his butt?
I heard he showed his butt.
[ Gasps ]
Meanwhile, everybody
is talking about
the new Aretha Franklin movie,
called "Respect,"
where Jennifer Hudson
plays Aretha,
and it is so good.
It has me like...
♪ You make me feel
like a natural what, what ♪
Now, I heard
the movie was so good
that it is getting
its own sitcom.
-That's not true.
-It is true.
And I get to play
the quirky next-door neighbor.
Aretha, I can hear your music
all the way next door.
And I love it!
[ "Seinfeld" theme music plays ]
[ Snickers ]
[ Laughter ]
Then, I found -- I forgot
we were gonna do this.
[ Laughter ]
-It's coming across.
-Then, I found out
that pizza was delivered
to astronauts in space,
and I was like, "What?!
You found someone
who delivers to space?
I can't even get pizza
delivered here on planet Earth."
They sent them a giant package
filled with ingredients,
and the astronauts
made their own pizzas.
And I was like, "What?
These astronauts have to
discover the final frontier
and make their own pizza?
They don't do enough for you?"
Someone heard about them
and was like,
"Oh, they have time.
They'll be able
to make their own pizzas
while keeping themselves alive
in space."
Then, I saw Rudy Giuliani
joined Cameo,
that website where you
pay celebrities to make videos.
And I was like, "What...
else do you expect him to do?
Shoot, it's not like
he can practice law.
He's a ghost!"
And then, I saw
that his Cameos cost $375,
and I was like, "What?"
Have you been on Cameo?
You could get like 10 cast
members from "Basketball Wives"
for that money.
This man is unemployed.
You know what I heard?
I heard he's gonna star
in a sitcom called
"Everybody Hates Rudy,"
and I get to play the quirky
next-door neighbor.
Hey, Rudy, I can hear your
Cameos all the way next door.
And I love it!
[ "Seinfeld" theme music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
-You were ready for that one.
-Uhhh, [Laughs]
somehow less ready.
Then, I heard "Jeopardy!"
hired two hosts,
and I was like, "What, what?
Why would they hire LeVar Burton
and a second person?
Then, I found out neither of
the two "Jeopardy!" hosts
are LeVar Burton,
and I was like, "What?!
Does this mean LeVar Burton
has some free time?"
I heard that he's gonna do
a variety show
called "LeVar-iety Hour,"
where he dances, sings,
and reads books.
And also, he's gonna have,
like, a sitcom
where he has a quirky
next-door neighbor,
and I get to play
that next-door neighbor.
And so I'll be like,
"LeVar, I can hear you
reading those books
all the way next door.
And I love it!"
[ "Seinfeld" theme music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
Also I can't stress this enough.
I heard Seth got Botox.
-I didn't!
It just looks like I did!
-This has been
"Amber Says What."
[ Theme music plays ]